georges avait deux ans quand je les
sauver il est plus qu'un ami il fait
partie de ma famille ne bouge pas un
muscle vous êtes dingues
ok très drôle toi et moi on rigole c'est
très drôle
le nouveau il rigole pas il pleure allez
debout c'est bon on va changer ta couche
allez on y va j'ai vu ton message pour
georges et il va bien j'en sais rien
georges c'est ok c'est moi ou il est
beaucoup plus gros non il est beaucoup
plus grand il faut trouver quelqu'un qui
pourra nous dire ce qu'est cette chose
je les trouvais non je blague
en fait c'est elle qui nous a trouvé qu
est ce qui lui arrive à mon pote
l'édition génétique vous connaissez les
changements vont être totalement
imprévisible force décuplée devance
vitesse accrue agilité démultiplier ou
et georges je dois le voir il est
dangereux
nous avons écrit un nouveau chapitre de
la sélection naturelle
le projet rampage fonctionne une autre
de vos petites expériences est en train
de se balader commence à une autre
[Musique]
bien sûr un loup ça vole pas
ça
sans balancer tout ce qu'on m'a sur ces
bestioles et fait évacuer la ville en
vitrine allons sauver le monde
j'ai des groupes recherchent pas lutter
vous savez il ya d'autres façons de
dialoguer avec les gens ouais je sais
mais c'est moins drôle
georges ça va j'ai pris mon pote